boxing is one thing but weight wise is a
big thing in mma like are you confident
right now
because just you outweigh him so much
like you let's say conor mcgregor
healthy you would just beat the piss at
a conor mcgregor
me because you're out weighing him by 70
pounds yeah but i also fought
professional at a high level that's what
i'm saying but you haven't fought at you
know
in a few years doesn't matter i'm a
black belt jiu jitsu i take him down and
choke him out
who's horny
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
two hours of sleep yeah what happened
hon papa couldn't sleep why
a lot of anxiety with this studio don't
worry about it
under the crunch time right now well let
me tell you this dude you want uh you
want the uh the studio to go bye-bye we
can make the studio go bye-bye no no no
little arsonist oh wanna set it on fire
no please don't me and pimp know a
couple guys
absolutely looks like you know his way
around a match pimp knows his way around
a match dude yeah pimp is uh
pimps yeah man he wears corduroy pants
it doesn't it was 130 degrees in the
valley yesterday those corduroys were on
ready to go yeah you don't look like a
short guy
no no he's not getting out the cavs
really once in a while you put a sock on
one of the hands
like mankind you put a dirty sock on and
[ __ ] shove in people's mouths that's
a salt these days
that is assault that is assault homeless
pimp is um yeah he's my guy
he uh when i first met him i thought he
was like genuinely [ __ ] and
just because of like the clothes he was
wearing and all that and his glasses and
and i thought it was like i thought like
giannis like brought like a make-a-wish
guy
and i was like i was like like you won a
contest sitting in the studio you know
cause
you know i thought like oh that's what
it is but then but then when i got to
meet him i was like oh no dude like this
guy's like legitimately
real and he's your guy guy now no no
pimp that's your man no no pimp is my
legitimate like i will protect homeless
pimp at all costs like i just called him
[ __ ] but i will apologize to him
profusely when we get in the car 100
yeah like i will i will say that was
just a bit i'm sorry like what do i need
to do to make this better
he's gonna say two grand yeah dude two
grand this all better be on the podcast
by the way
it is yeah we're always recording yeah
okay yeah yeah because dude
look at [ __ ] nick dude nick's the
only guy i've ever met
that's not [ __ ] but also wears
velcro sneakers
are those velcro
why do you got velcro on dude because my
girl is sick of my truth
i do it every really brendan from now on
every time you post your kicks of the
day i need nick to post this picture of
the day
i need to see what pieces of [ __ ] he has
on his feet
your girl your girl bought you velcro
just because she was sick of you
uh having your shoes hunt died yeah yeah
are they always untied what are you for
i don't know i don't know but it was a
problem when i was a child too and my
grandma got me velcro shoes and now my
girlfriend did it for me
just staying on the velcro and i [ __ ]
love them you know what man it fits the
show though dude because
you know half of theo's fans wear velcro
shoes
do you guys have to tie your shoes in
the morning do you just slip into your
shoes because if you're tying your shoes
i'm saving time you guys are idiots
you are i usually i usually slip into my
shoe
but i always like to buy a bigger shoe
like i'm actually a size 11 foot i got a
little i got a little bit of a smaller
foot for a man but i go 12 and a half
i just started wearing a size 14. i've
been a 13 since
high school yeah i started doing 14. and
you're like a little wiggle room well
i have white well no your foot is
getting bigger because you're on
steroids
dude because that chain was a little
looser yesterday dude daddy's neck's
getting a little thick
that's gonna be just watch the
progression the podcast just gets
tighter and tighter
yeah dude no man so how'd your filming
go for your tv show
the filming your show hollywood now bro
show hollywood i'm about to access
hollywood mario lopez in about an hour
watch that's coming out i'm going to try
to tickle mary lopez's balls or do
something like cancel
no but nobody's going to watch it on tv
but the clip would be cool
it'll be hopefully it goes viral tommy
can beat him in a boxing match that'll
trigger him i will
i'm going to tell him what you said i'm
going to tell him because yesterday on
you came on my show the chrissy chaos
podcast tuesday's 11
eastern time um you you came on my
podcast and you said you met mario lopez
once and you talked to him about some
stuff and he wouldn't drop
the whole hollywood thing he's been in
hollywood so long he can't drop the
hey i'm mario lopez how you doing i'm
like dude just talk like a normal
chin was there i thought we were gonna
get kicked out i literally thought we're
gonna get kicked out you were doing
access hollywood uh well
when we we filmed our show at his studio
he was on fire blow the bell
yeah he was on below the bell but at his
studio because we went to his he'd only
do if we went to his studio so like all
right so we drive down to universal
we do it there yeah chin was running all
the audio and cameras and me and him it
got pretty heated
yeah i thought for sure i'm not even
joking i thought we're gonna get kicked
out because they got really heated about
the conor mcgregor floyd mayweather
uh boxing match do you think mario lopez
was like was he gonna get was there a
point where you think this could get
violent
never right no i would slap it later but
kicked out yeah
could you imagine beating the [ __ ] at ac
slater how funny would that be
if you just i mean kick the [ __ ] up or
if he caught you
with you know a roundhouse kick and
knocked you out never yeah but that
would be
i would whoop his ass and keep yelling
out zach morris for no reason just keep
screaming again dude i'm
if that ever if that ever tell you it
went bad because when he went to sit
down i said oh you're not gonna sit
backwards like ac slater and it
triggered him and then
it didn't go well after that he got
angry about that yeah i don't think he
likes those so
although he did the reboot which [ __ ]
sucks
sucks right is he a little baby guy too
he look is he a small petite man
small hand you know handsome dude oh
hundred percent
a lot of makeup on though yeah even for
the podcast
interesting interesting i look like a
[ __ ] you know i look like a
freaking weathered worm next to him i'm
excited to do it you know i mean that's
what
having a tv show does is at least it
gets you on these type of press but the
actual filming of the show
blows dude fi i'm just building f
he's got a good career though i'm not
hating mario lopez he's crushing it i
mean if you want to be that guy a
hundred percent
i'm basically the mario lopez showtime
like they used me like i'm him
yeah yeah yeah 100 mary lopez
showtime yeah which is a good credit i
mean that's where you're doing the 18t
bud light limerita center yeah and not
but he's doing the actual att
center yeah yeah yeah yeah but hey i'm
not doing anything
i don't even have 18 ti verizon who's
this [ __ ]
this this could be our absolutely
electric spoke person let's hear what he
has to say
hey cats nation hey brandon hey theo hey
nick and chin
i'm tate mullenberg i play basketball at
the university of tampa
i'm originally from iowa i'm a small
forward
with this new name and image likeness
you can now get sponsored
or create your own brand and i chose
king the sting because it's my favorite
podcast
and with my two favorite comedians
brandon theo
i think i'd be a good athlete because i
do have a mullet
it's grown in and also
i have the american flag sunburned into
my back
now i don't have that gang
no you made it better just put on the
hdmi oh here we go now we're back in
action
let lopez just see the end nick yeah i
want to see the end because i need to
see if he does something because right
now it just sounds like someone who has
a traumatic brain injury
so poor guy what's what's tough is to to
be the first sponsored
athlete and you're you're a white
forward in division
is the university of tampa even division
one yeah it is division one
yeah we sure i'll look it up yeah make
sure tampa's division one
is their football team and also
i have the american flag sunburned into
my back i love this kid again
i also like it buzz buzz i love him dude
i wanted to see a little action though
i want to see you play him he's got some
stuff for us i got some more videos for
you let me see let me see let me check
his jumper let me see if he can boof it
he's gotta because if you're gonna be a
white guy with a mullet you gotta be
able to either you gotta have a dope
three
or you gotta get a joke on somebody the
token white guy that shoots in the
corner yeah you can i don't
i don't wanna sponsor a guy that's like
taking charges and doing the little
things
no like let's see what let's see if he's
got skill skill yeah i don't know what
sponsor yeah who just plays defense
oh is this him hey
that was a layup that was the layout
let's try it again
let's let me see that again because i
was like oh if this guy windmilled it
yeah i thought he's about to [ __ ]
hear a minor
that's a layup that's listen i can't
speak for theo but if because i'm
sitting in his place today
no you have the power of attorney today
for theo okay then i say
i say let's sponsor him i i what's the
sponsor include
uh we'll just send him some cat's merch
and he can wrap us down in tampa but i
love the idea of cats athletes barstool
is getting like every
hot college athlete so we have guys like
uh we're gonna have the guys
yeah yeah we had a lacrosse player reach
out to me
okay that was serious now watch this one
this is an actual for real windmills
is this the same kid yeah this is the
same kid
okay so now this can now he's proved
that he can actually win mill dunk a
basketball
um granted it's you know it's in like
you know it's just a little alley-oop
not in the game or anything
but i would feel comfortable
representing a kitty look at
that who wants some he's cute he's cute
he does look yeah we know his name let's
look at his stats
muellenberg or something is he a starter
yeah she can't be coming off the bench
papa
listen he transferred from a juco school
and last year they only played a couple
games at tampa
look did he go off though does he have a
statue at the university like my boy
chrissy d here
is he in the division three hall of fame
what's up let me ask you this
let me say this i'm i'm cool with
sponsoring him
i am for our first sponsor but if we're
going to continue to do this
we're going to need some black guys it
can't be all white kids with mulch if
we're going to want to put a good team
out there
you're going to need to get some african
americans out there yeah to
kind of want to be sponsored by us as
well because he's not going to cut it
all
i don't want to be that the whole idea
of oh we got a team of white guys
let's see if they can win it's nice on
paper but they lose big
a lot yes so we're winners here so we
need some black guys to be on our can
you name an
all-white team not really these days no
dude on division one no man
you know the onl the last great
all-white team was the one that hitler
put out
facts do you guys ever hear about
grinnell
in iowa grinnell dude they score like
160 points a game they just bomb threes
do you have somebody from grinnell want
to be sponsored
uh no but they're all white they're all
white but they lose a lot though
division three division two but they are
a team that i've been watching i'm a kid
because they score like a hundred and
sixty points a game and the leading
still lose
they lose all the time because they play
absolutely no [ __ ] defense
it's like an all-star game no but their
coach's philosophy because it's the one
coach
his philosophy is out shoot your
opponent don't he doesn't even teach
defense
he's like we will all be three you have
to be a [ __ ] sniper to play for this
team you should probably be
fired especially oh yeah winning games
they do not win but yeah monmouth had
grinnell 1443
but they lo oh they won this one but
still if you gave up 125 points
dude you're scoring 143 at d3 yeah
dude it's not bad they just literally
just dude right away
red flag everybody's watching the chord
yeah
except for the tall black fella i would
like yeah if oh no dude anytime grinnell
plays a real basketball team and when i
mean a real basketball team i mean
three or four or mostly african
americans even two
they lose by a hundred yeah like they
lose by a hundred
because it's all the tokens scored 200
points on them before but they've scored
130 but they've lost they've they've
given up two because i mean it's just 84
points and a half
dude you have to see and when they get
dunked on these guys get [ __ ]
teabagged by by like actual athletes
it's hilarious
it's hot out here daddy oh put a needle
in your arm huh
or get a liquid iv yeah when it's uh
when it hits that 110 out here in the
valley dog
shooting up won't do anything for you
but drinking up will
with liquid iv man get that sipper baby
one stick of liquid iv
that watermelon for the summer oh dude
16 ounces of water
it hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water alone who's drinking water
alone is it the 1800s come on bro
not only that but the product tastes
great with flavors like watermelon
strawberry and lemon my favorite man can
stains
contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange
as much potassium as a banana it's
healthier than all those sugary drinks
you don't need that man
you don't need that grab your liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco
you got to be a member though i have a
friend who can get you in or you can get
25
off when you go to liquidity.com use the
code kats at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code
cats at liquidity.com let's go
look man a lot of things you try to mail
something you can't even mail it i went
to the mail place the other day they
told me to come back next week
can't have that man people are waiting
for their packages maybe it's this past
weekend merch whatever it is
you gotta get it out you gotta trust a
man that's why shipstation is the number
one choice
of online sellers that's it that's right
ship station
is the way to do it no matter how you
sell your goods if you have a good and
you want to get it to your customer get
it to samadhi
shopify xc your own website shipstation
funnels all your orders in one simple
interface
that you can manage from anywhere even
your freaking cell phone
could do it on your own you can do it on
my cell phone
that's right just use the offer code
kats to get a 60 day free trial
that's two free months to ship
ship your face off dude mail your face
to your fat
friend yeah just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in cats that
shipstation.com
enter the offer code k-ats make ship
happen yeah yeah no
they make the division three like you
know finals start sponsoring wnba
players
they need money do you realize that w
like the hi i googled this the other day
the highest paid player in the wnba it's
like 400k
no they i saw they make like a hundred
thousand dollars a year that's the
market value though
what do you want us to do you have a
business to run so what do you think i
mean do they have
like what do they do do they have only
fans in the offseason
but they're not like well if you're la
spark you're [ __ ] with 100k in l.a but
i guess you're in like
aisles you're playing for the indiana
fever yeah you're both yeah
i like that tampa bay is uh d2
d2 okay listen division two
i like this kid he's got a fun white
mullet
he's he can dunk i like him as a first
sponsor athlete i again was the first
guy to sign on
cats now that we're saying first team
all cats yeah
now that we're saying though that this
is what we're doing here at the cat show
i'd like to really get some actual you
know black athletes yes
because i just want to be unless we're
playing lacrosse so we're going to stick
with white then we want to go white
but yeah i i he was the first one i love
that he he went for it i think we should
say yes but yeah send in more
highlight reels yes uh more athletes
let's see what you got
yeah why and why what you're going to do
for the cat's brand to push us forward
yeah these kids want hardcore
son who who's gonna get the tattoo
here's the thing we sponsor mma fighter
he gets a tattoo on his back
what if now if you play for team cats if
you're a basketball player playing for
team cats are you going to sponsor them
with velcro sneakers what are they going
to
what are they going to hit the hardwood
kit those kids need cash doug be
cash right yeah they get a bet they got
to buy food for after the game and [ __ ]
drinks for their friends so wait so this
whole college athlete thing means like
like let's take a zion williamson type
let's let's go
let's say he was coming into duke this
year so he would be making he could be
like nike would give him a million
dollar like millions of dollars to play
or
it's only endorsement no there's no cap
it's only endorsement so
they can't use the name and likeness of
the school so he can't
have a picture of him in a duke jersey
holding a gatorade
it'd just be a picture of him in like
normal clothes but i'm saying gatorade
could give him 25 million dollars for
that so
that's what i'm saying so we're entering
a phase now where the college athletes
the freshmen and sophomores who are
absolute studs let's stay with
basketball going to the nba
are going to be multi-millionaires at 19
20 years old they are already though
we this has been going on for the
longest
they're just not going to be [ __ ]
canceled over it you know what i'm
saying oh so you're saying zion
williamson
you're one of two he already had
millions of dollars he got paid it was
all like just illegal 100
yeah okay now it's legal now it's just
out in the open but now it's like that
that girl from lsu the gymnast she's
gonna make the most money
like she's this hot girl she has like a
million followers on instagram and tick
tock like she'll make the most money
well now i know like at least like with
recruiting out of high school
like now all of the basketball players
who get recruited at high school they're
all like have
huge followings on social media if you
don't have a big social media you they
you don't get looked at it's the same
like in entertainment like you have to
have a social media presence
see you as stand-up sam stand up our guy
taylor uh yeah he doesn't have much of a
social media presence he has seven posts
on instagram and he's on private that's
a problem
uh but here's something to think about
christy d so
we we both have kids so let's say your
kid uh
is uh you have a boy or just two girls
two girls and a step son
okay so we'll keep it with your
blood-related one so
uh your two girls so let's say your
oldest has
she's a baller in volleyball or where
the [ __ ] she's playing okay
and she has jesus christ and she has all
these offers is this the lsu girl yep
yummy yummy she didn't get paid
[Music]
so she has all these offers from schools
right texas florida
california freaking lsu usc ucla
and and she's gonna get she's a looker
right is she 18
yeah yeah she's she's 18 yeah okay so so
she's going to go to
one of these schools and let's say
gatorade or whoever offered a million
dollars
she goes to school at usc the states
didn't take half of that
she goes to school in florida or texas
the the state's not going to touch it
you got to pay federal but not state
taxes
right so most the recruits are going to
end up going to texas
arizona florida because they're not they
don't want to have their [ __ ] to go away
so you're saying what would i do would i
would i wouldn't you tell your daughter
like yo
keep all your money and go to [ __ ]
florida oh a hundred percent like who's
gonna go to sc or ucla now or stanford
no dude yeah no especially if you're
like getting real big-time endorsement
money you're not going there
no yeah dude no you're giving half your
[ __ ] money a hundred percent dude i
would tell her to go to school in
florida because that's probably where
her mother will be in prison
true so yeah california's gonna be
[ __ ] dude yeah
oh yeah no dude california there's no
there's
i mean look dude i i live in new york so
it's like we have the same
tax issue whatever your shirt says miami
though it does say well i'll do it for
mary lopez this is mary lopez i
this is the mayor lopez inspired shirt i
and you want to talk because that you
wear the build shirts which i love
i'm wearing the roosevelt's kuna flex
they're called this is another one that
hides the fat in the nipples this is
another one that
[ __ ] shrinks it in it's like wearing
spanx on your chest yeah i'll
let you try it out yeah face of a cop
body of a lunch lady 100 lunch lady
asked yes
i uh i was doing well the last time i
came on king this thing was really doing
well but it
went off the rails but why no gym no
exercise because it's [ __ ] true tv
shows
mentally ruining my life craft food
services i'm all that [ __ ] dude yeah i'm
all that and i'm just depressed tired
sitting i'm like oh i'll get an in-n-out
burger i'll eat in a lettuce wrap and
then i eat it in a lettuce wrap and i
eat three orders of animal fries yeah
but have a diet coke
yeah so when you're fine you feel good
in my mind i'm like i'm just not eating
bread
yeah ice cream don't have bread yeah you
know
so um yeah but new york man you know
it's the same problem but my thing is
it's like
all our friends who like move to like
austin or whatever like they're
miserable besides rogue in their midst
so that's the thing is
logan could live in iraq with his money
he'd have a family he should live in
iraq with this
well he could be hey everyone it's great
down here yeah but we don't have a
billion dollars
dude could you imagine saddam hussein on
the john the joe roger show like yeah i
did it'd be
awesome how great would that be
just him talking to hussein i would love
it dude
everybody has come to austin we're like
yeah but we don't have a billion dollars
to play along i know
i know well that's the thing but they
people move back because i get the other
and i love other parts of the country
but
it's tough to live if you're an
entertainment or an athlete you don't
want to live in these other places you
want to live
in the coastal city there's an energy
here there's an energy here that you
have to kind of live around
business will always be here yeah you
have to so i get that there's no taxes
in this state or that state but
then it's like you know i think it evens
out actually
how so because you're not going to get
the same opportunities right so then
you're not going to make that income so
then
the money you save by moving there you
you don't have those opportunities
anymore so you're basically breaking
even
yeah you're not living in la or new york
yeah that's true i know
i know i i don't know i guess these i
guess like you know my kid though
yeah well let's see hopefully she wants
to go i don't even by the time she's 18
by the time both our kids are 18.
dude college may be an obsolete thing
that people are like why would we spend
why would we send our children to
college it does genuinely nothing for
them agree
that's a very big possibility like in
just 10 12 years it could be like no
that's a dumb thing to do
yeah it's out what's this nick return of
blot my aunt
oh oh [ __ ] there we go what up king in
this thing this is noah from nashville
i gotta flaunt my aunt for you this is
yeta
she is from north carolina she currently
still lives with my grandmother in north
carolina
in their childhood home so she's really
grown up a lot and
she has a bunch of hobbies she likes
gardening
she likes cooking she likes drunk
texting me late at night asking for
photos of my daughter
and substitute teaching i think and uh
yeah she is single right now but
her signature move is getting with like
fat guys that have a lot of money and
then rise they're going to propose
she [ __ ] ends it moves on to the next
guy so that's
awesome um she's super [ __ ] funny she
used to
make fun of me and call me fat when i
was little and it wasn't traumatizing
and yeah dude brendan i saw you
at zany's and that last photo that
you'll see here
you dress like my super gay dad does
which is [ __ ] sick and i feel at home
when i'm with you
[Laughter]
and gang butt [ __ ]
that is what i was wearing in nashville
this kid is legitimately funny
like that kid is legitimately funny
you've seen him he's sent in videos
before this guy
i don't think so he's like legitimately
like a funny kid yeah and eddie was like
let me know if this isn't good enough i
was like this is the
dude you should do comedy man like he
gets it yeah he's great
yeah dude that's hilarious dad's awesome
dude
like that's like a a guy that i know um
his dad like left the family for like
three four months and came back and
fully like was trans
like fully went to thailand and got and
didn't say anything and and the mother
had known but the father had asked the
mother like please don't tell the
children
i want to tell them i want to tell them
and he's and he said like literally dude
it's a friend
as dave came back as donna yeah he says
he's a stand-up comedian actually this
kid lance and he barely talks about it
he's talked about on podcast i'm not
saying anything that's private but he
was like yeah i opened the door like i
literally opened the door like with a
baseball glove on because mom said dad
was coming home from the airport
and i opened up and he was he looked
like my mom like he had
full tits hair like he had fully
transitioned surgery and was like
and he was like i want to play baseball
with you and his dad was like we could
still play baseball and he was like no
he can't yeah he's like no i
can't i can't play baseball with you
anymore but i was like dude what a mind
[ __ ]
i feel like i feel like the dad went
about it all wrong
yeah give the kid a heads up dude oh my
god dude if my dad
ever went trans you have to see dude my
father is one of
is there an uglier guy than my father uh
no yeah right
and he's got that lazy eye like oh he
has a [ __ ] up eye oh yeah can we pull
up a pic
see if you can pull a picture of tony de
stefano just up so i don't know if
tony he might be because we put him on
our podcast you get the [ __ ] up eye
from uh prison dude i don't even [ __ ]
know at all
i don't i is that him no no no that's
not him is your dad hulk
put on put on go to my instagram go to
my instagram there's a there there's a
video of
the thumbnail of him at least um no my
dad's an ugly guy yeah he's just one of
those guys like and it's one of those
things where like my mom like harvey
weinstein yeah my mom was like you know
she was like as soon as
like i was pregnant she was like what am
i like what am i doing like why did i
have a child with this man
first question we want to have sex with
this one how did i warm up this guy
look at this guy ah
oh wow yeah he it was funny in this
interview with my dad like pimp just
asked him
he goes so when did you know you're when
did you think your son was probably gay
and my dad just goes
seven he just immediately he just like
he didn't even take a beat he goes seven
just look he lost he lost a hundred
dollars because he bet that i was gonna
be a girl
that's a true well i pretty much i
should have won because
you are you you i guess i was born i was
born tucked down looked like a non
was there every time you were actually
he was gay chris was gay of course
what was the first age where you're like
uh seven
also when i was younger yeah ready to go
seven yeah
[Laughter]
like with my family now like with this
chrissy kaz podcast like
dude my dad jasmine [ __ ]
um uh uh tt jerry jasmine's transgender
uncle like these are all like these
people are like
legitimately like characters on my show
but i never put them on
i put tt jerry on camera and my dad once
in a while but like
jasmine stays off but i kind of like i
don't know i kind of feel like with my
podcast i'm
aren't we i kind of feel like we're
doing like a mini like reality show i
was just gonna say
in a way this is a tv show it's a little
bit of a reality show you've gone full
hollywood
now and you're pitching a tv show and i
appreciate it but uh
you could definitely do a tv show would
you like to be involved
i don't know what i'd play in that what
about i'd be like a guy that like
delivers your [ __ ] sandwiches or
something
dude how funny is this one of the one of
their because well i don't know if
you'll see a picture of homeless
maybe you guys have put it up in the
episode but they were one of my friends
on camera my friend oh he's on camera
okay
one of my friends uh my friend jill
shout out jill she wanted to hook
one of her friends up her friend was
just recently single and you and i
had done like a little youtube thing and
i had put like film by the homeless pimp
but she thought you were the homeless
pimp
so she texted and she was like texting
me and
jasmine she was like oh i didn't know
homeless simple as a hottie like that
and i was like
yeah i guess i was like i guess if
that's what you're in i guess if you
yeah that's if that's what you're into
man but
uh sure i was like i was like yeah i'll
make it happen yeah and then she goes oh
my god that's fantastic whatever and
then i was like literally is like going
through the channels with her friends
and got jasmine my girlfriend like on
the line and was like
and then jazz was like yeah i know he's
cute like he's definitely cute but
she was like danielle because danielle
is like danielle is
you know like hot you know like girl
like yeah whatever and she was like she
was like no she's like
listen she was like jasmine was like let
me be clear homeless is very cute she's
like you're saying like drop dead
gorgeous and she's like
you know he's very cute she was like and
he's a nice guy and she's like i don't
know what your friend wants to be
involved you know
whatever i don't know but then like
literally like as the days go on she's
like all right we're going to set this
thing up she goes
let me just send me like like one more
picture of him because like she's looked
through all the pictures on his
instagram already so i sent her
a picture of homeless people from my
instagram she goes who's that
and i was like that's the homeless pimp
and she calls me dying laughing she goes
i thought brendan shaw was the homeless
man
i was like bro i would have paid any
amount of money
to [ __ ] ha like let me borrow your
camera
me film you show up to this date with
this girl and then just the [ __ ]
could you imagine brandon you think
you're going to deal with bread and chop
it it's the homeless of him
honestly dude i'm telling that story and
i bet you women right here right now are
like i'd rather go out with the homeless
pimp i bet you there's women in this
world i think you're harder than brendan
100 everyone has their type man he's
cute looking behind his glass he's a
cute kid
yeah he's got a cute face i mean but but
don't you struggle with your pronouns or
some [ __ ]
um yeah depends on the day no that could
be tough no here's here's what's good
about
this he's 29 years old so he's just on
the cusp of like that like you know
they them thing stuff so he understands
it all
but he also went to an all-boy catholic
school and from whitestone queens it's
one of the most racist neighborhoods in
the world
so he kind of has that tough guy
upbringing but with the understanding of
the they
them so he's perfect actually because he
does he's not like that but he gets it
and he knows when i go too far
he's like hey you got to pull that is
the daniela girl latin
uh no she's uh like asian yeah yeah yeah
but it was the funniest thing
i mean i still sometimes i'm up at night
laughing about
if i would love to have been there and
just watch she's like what the [ __ ]
and i would have taught and i would have
known and i would told you dude wear
your best corduroys
wear your [ __ ] adult swim shirt don't
shower
get out there yeah it was great dude
man if you want to feel that heat you
want to feel that powder in your body
and feel your butt get active you know
how to do it baby
green up daddy green up hose down
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens
the most comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage i've ever put
in this temple temple
temple's temple temple's a university
dude and that's more of a grade school
that's where uh bill cosby went that's
true dude
okay oh look i'll say dude
verde de atletico one tasty scoop of
verde de alettico
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food sourced ingredients i'm talking
about an athletic ground talking about
drinking a multivitamin it fills the
nutritional gaps and your diet increases
energy focus do you need all that stuff
yeah
you do all right and listen right now
athletic greens is doubling down and
supporting your immune system all right
during the winter months even though
it's the summer
so much be healthy they're offering you
guys free one year supply of vitamin d
loves that d i do not get five free
travel packs with your first purchase
when you go to athletic greens.com kats
join the healthexpertsathlete.com
podcasters
go-getters around the world who make a
daily commitment to their health every
day
visit athleticgreens.com kats and get
your free
year supply of that d smoke my dick
these days look i realize that this i uh
i'm not good at being an employee
and i also work for myself you wanna be
a boss i also work for myself man
i work for myself and it's a lot of work
yep that's where helium comes in man
imagine the freedom of being your own
boss like me and theo yeah we're
exhausted
stressed out all the time theo's looking
older gaining weight
not a big deal running a business that's
a lot of things bro
yep running a business that best suits
your lifestyle and schedule
helium 10 wants to tell you how to
embark on a smart career
where you call the shots right daddy
start your own amazon business the best
way to work from home and be your own
boss is by becoming an
amazon seller it's not just an online
superstore amazon is not that it's
actually a marketplace that connects
buyers and sellers and anyone can become
a seller thanks to fulfillment
by amazon or fba and thanks to helium 10
software helium 10 is an all-in-one
software suite designed to help people
just like you launch just like build
and manage a profitable business on
amazon
it's business in a box helium 10 has
been used by over 1 million people
worldwide
no invention or big idea required helium
10 will find
you the right product to sell and handle
so many other aspects of your business
it's basically just providing an
infrastructure that you're going to need
to get it done the startup costs for
launching a business on amazon
are much smaller than you think a
fraction yeah man handle these nuts be a
boss
work when you want to work from whenever
you want to work take advantage
of this deal helium 10 get 50 off your
first month
of helium 10 platinum account when you
go to helium10.com
k-a-t-s that's h-e-l-i-u-m
one zero dot com slash
k-a-t-s don't wait to get 50 off your
first month go to helium10.com
slash cats be a boss uh this guy's got a
debate club uh
it was actually came in before the
announcement of tyson fury having covet
though but
oh i didn't even know that what's up
guys been a fan for a long time my name
is mike from wisconsin
and i got a debate club for you guys
which fight are you more excited for the
wilder fight
or the hezbollah fight i gotta go with
hezbollah just because he's the cutest
little thing i've seen i don't know he's
the little khabib
oh my god he's close he's like 18 but he
has like he's the biggest thing i've
ever seen
he's cute i would say and he sits on his
hand
oh but but also he's joking who's
one more thing i want to shout out
milwaukee and the bucks hopefully the
players are still going on when this
airs uh
[Music]
but this is a question this is a
syndrome right they're not children
no yes he's like 18 right but he's like
the hottest thing in mma social media
because when he first started having
videos go viral people thought he was a
child and then and he was with can he
legitimately fight though no
like it's it's he can't absolutely not
he's just like but i don't think so i
mean they're from dagestan so
it's [ __ ] what they do but they were
beefing over like
acting not right during ramadan and
someone's trying to put a fight on
between those two yeah and khabib
khabib what kind of thing right there
dagestan
dag because he's from the country i
watched an hbo thing where like
their leader is like so gay
they kill you that's the thing is like
it's like how come people don't talk
about that country why is it always like
the united states
what do you think yeah what do you mean
that's what they do over there
that's just what they can't control that
no but it's like go to russia and
tell them to be cool to the journalists
yeah that's my thing yeah razman
khadriov has his own mma league like
it's it's a tough would you go fight in
that league or no
absolutely not no even i'm too gay for
them yeah
oh my god my jeans are too tight you
know dude they would execute me man
i know that because those guys like
they're like the best fighters though
because they really
don't take over mma yet because they
grow up in [ __ ] doing it yeah they grow
up wrestling at like two
right like grizzly bears and [ __ ] yeah
dude i know they're gonna take over i
watch this husband of fight though where
can i get it
over wilder fury though no i like well
yeah well first of all i didn't even
know fury had covered is he out is the
fight out
yeah postponed to october does he have
covet covert he's just popping his team
has coveted and he has codes like he's
literally
what they say a lot but a lot of
fighters and i'm not saying this but a
lot of fighters are saying that
to give him more time interesting you
know what i'm saying papakova
because he hasn't looked great in the in
the post in the press conferences and
stuff so
if you want more times like oh we all
test positive dude dude wilder is one of
those guys though like he
can like legitimately kill someone in
the ring if like he like you've seen him
in fury fight the two times yeah
that's the one fury and got like the
undertaker when he thought he was
unconsciously popped up and then the
second time beat the [ __ ] out of him
but but i mean getting punched in the
face by dante wilder would has to
really insane that has to really stop
the better question you can add that kid
into hezbollah
but the better question would be are you
more excited for fury wilder
or woodley uh jake paul
oh yeah woodley jake paul are you the
press conference i didn't
was it good yeah it's just tough
but i've heard boxing people like you
know boxing professionals say that
jake paul can actually hit his skills
yeah they say he actually has like
legitimate skills
we'll really find out against woodley
woodley can [ __ ] [ __ ] woodley's a
real real boxer
yes he's been boxing yeah at wild card
since 2006.
he's a born boxer like he's a
professional wrestler but yeah but but
um
but what who's the hall of famer but
like okay but like jake paul can box but
like could jake paul
fight a for real professional box no
that's just not not yet but also
he's just not like in a in you give him
more time he could
what he's doing at his level right now
is impressive no i'm very impressed by
him too but again
i think that woodley fights me tough for
him so if you put like jake paul against
like ryan garcia he'd get hurt that
very bad ryan garcia would hurt him very
badly destroy him yeah got it
but he only has three fights but is it a
weight class thing too
like like you know not at that level not
at that at that level it's just like
you're if you're a better boxer better
especially ryan garcia is young and can
[ __ ] box dude right like that's what
he does right
but like like it's like saying how would
jake paul do open it up for you
okay but let me say this let me say this
you know what i'm saying how would jake
paul do opening up for you imagine he
[ __ ] blew you off the stage
oh my god i would be dying in the back
nothing's funnier to a comic than when
another comic just [ __ ] goes out
there and
eats one yeah i'll eat [ __ ] yeah well
dude
literally as a comment bombs yeah yeah
bombs we're all laughing in the back
dude there couldn't be anything worse at
all it dude get knocked out
[ __ ] terrible and it's embarrassing
no but
it sucks when you know you're bombing
yeah you still have like
if especially if it's your show you have
an hour and you're 20 minutes in and oh
yeah
eating dude like i got 40 more minutes
out of this or like in new york when you
sit in the back of the comedy cellar and
it's like somebody's just you know
you're just
sitting there watching go and make
somebody starts eating and you can just
tell they just start to sweat you just
know their back
is just getting hotter and hotter and
they're like so where are you from
it was weird today i'm like you're
[ __ ] bombing you stink
[Laughter]
your asshole's like oh dude i um you
want to quit
let me ask you this though as in because
because boxing is one thing
but weight wise is a big thing in mma
like are you confident right now
because just you out weigh them so much
like you let's say conor mcgregor
healthy you would just beat the piss at
a conor mcgregor
me because you're out weighing by 70
pounds yeah but i also fought
professionally at a high level that's
what i'm saying but you haven't fought
at you know in a few years
it doesn't matter i'm a black belt so
i'll take him down and choke him out
who's horny um send that clip to your
girl
so he's a black man in jiu jitsu he used
to fight professionally here's the
homeless pimp
showing up with corduroys and new
balances on dude
and conor now has a broken leg so i
think yeah i'm saying if connor was
healthy because because with boxing
like first of all like you know cause
like like weight classes like like let's
say like in boxing like
tyson fury versus canelo canelo is going
to get killed yes
potassium fury's the best the best that
heavyweight and has all the skills
canelo can beat up a low level
professional heavyweight for sure for
sure
okay okay i'm just i wasn't sure but not
like a professional heavyweight like uh
middle of the road middleweight i'm
sorry heavyweight no
right got it who would you have for jake
paul conor mcgregor who do you think
would win that boxing match dude with
those headphones on you look like warren
from something about marriage
before you were going to go back frankie
all right what was your question [ __ ]
riri
did he bring those or those arms dude
they're mine
what are you doing
[Music]
what's this handsome devil dude this
looks like me if i was in the
confederacy
[Laughter]
this looks like the homeless people
you've got a [ __ ] it's aaron from
lincoln nebraska
i got a king in her stinger for you guys
chewie's
you don't know what it is you pour the
beer in the shoe
and you spit in it and chug it
personally
not a fan but wanted to see what you
guys think
i'll let this guy show you how to do it
chin gang buddy
it's on your instagram bring up the i
did a shoei of i was going to say
something
the guy who's uh [ __ ] uh
he came on my show and we did a shoei
and he so you lost a bet or something
right no
i just did it because it's tattoo of us
i [ __ ] love the dude and he's known
for shoei so i was like i'll do a shoe
with you
and i had a brand new shoe that reebok
said i'm like let's use this on one shoe
so you put what i didn't know this i
thought you just poured the bear in the
shoe and drink it well you don't
everybody has to [ __ ] spit in it and
they just don't spit they [ __ ] spit
so you have to drink these dudes spit
yeah like loogies dude look at this
oh man that's oh so he does it because
we all kind of spin
it you've got to take a name take the
knee for it
what is that with people like what's the
point of adding the steps
oh you took your own spit it's all three
of us
[Applause]
oh you did this years ago yes oh my god
dude how to drink a shoei
here's a cat's fan this was just the
saturn
because he won the guy tai tui vasa the
guy brenda did it with was on the card
this is he's known for this
how did he think of this what's the
point uh
oh new zealand okay he's from new
zealand okay okay
anybody want to try one i'll do one no i
can't do it i can't
i have a duels i can't i can't just i
can't it's fair
oh no i can't i would dude i can't i
genuinely can't not last time
because i can't with spit and all that i
just can't do it i would i just
if i was doing mario lopez i would have
did it but i can't do it i can't i can't
i can't no because i can't [ __ ] up my
shirt i do it i got mario lopez i can't
do it
there's no way i can't i can't drink the
spit also i can't do it i also um i i
have coven
you got the delta i have the delta
variant i have covad
the pimp's not vaccinated um
whoa oh real beer
dude oh what god whose shoes did you
steal from a lunch lady no dude these
dudes these things are
a piece of [ __ ] no dude i was gonna say
dude
yeah dude dude these are nick's new
shoes
[Laughter]
they didn't have velcro so i figured i'd
give them to the show
let me get the laces out of there go
ahead anybody anybody want to step up
and do it with them homeless pimp chin
of course i do homeless pimp freaky
no i'm fun are you sure i'm fine i'll do
it no dude i knew you'd come around all
right fine i'll do it i'll let you guys
spit in my mouth
fine i'll freaking do it absolutely
there we go
nick wow these are pretty sweet i mean
this is amazing dude
oh my god i feel like that could you
imagine been out of beer in years
really no what do you drink whiskey oh
i'm sorry whiskey dude
all right so now what now what just
you have to spit in it though that's the
point of it
yeah man i'll spend time spitting your
own since we're all in separate rooms
yeah cheers boys cheers
absolutely man bubbles here it is ready
to go
oh what the [ __ ] is this dude give me
another show
hear me lit for mario lopez dude i'm
[ __ ] trying to [ __ ] him
chris is never going to want to come in
the show again we make them [ __ ] do
something you made me you made me drink
out of a shoe
you made me eat the asian fish suck the
fish dick
yeah dude that fish was disgusting
disgusting dude
disgusting that shoot yeah i mean
drinking out of that shoe
it actually wasn't the worst thing size
10. it's a clean shoe you're supposed to
do it with your shoe but
you know there's something in my shoe
you use your aren't you no there's
something in my shoes oh that's over
here there's something in your shoe yeah
it fell in my mouth i had to spit it out
what was it like something black and
long
black and long chin where are you where
are you coming from oh my god
shoot did you get it what's going on
chin
oh man all right we did chewie's that
was nice that wasn't i think
honestly dude honestly off two hours of
sleep that felt nice every time i have a
beer before like 10 a.m i love it so
much like i genuinely think i am an
alcoholic i'm just keeping it at bay
like i'm genuinely keeping it at bay
because i get addicted to sweets i eat
sweets and bad food but if i start to
get in shape
and eliminate those i think i might go
for the brewskis i'm with you yeah dude
in the pandemic i was a straight-up bona
fide alcohol honey why did you only
sleep two hours though what's going on
did you sleep dad
why she couldn't you're stressed yes
because
it's just anxiety from the studio [ __ ]
from the new studio yeah it was a bad
move i don't think so i think it'll work
out
and just sit there and say nothing it
was a bad move and then so what do you
got over here
uh this guy's got uh kinder stinger for
us i think you guys can relate
this guy yeah this guy i mean he looks
like [ __ ] i mean he just looks like he
was looting
what's up brennan and theo cat
chappelle looks like a cop nick he does
also from wisconsin
he looks like he turns off the body
camera
little ones gotta watch shapes
all day long but it's worth it because
look at how cute this kid is
jack can you say one thing for me
gang gang buzz buzz
hilarious imagine how funny
what can you say one thing for me it
just was like trump 2024.
or he's like he's all no no no no no
drop something he's like no
i'll edit this that kid yeah dude i get
that and well you know
i mean all the little kid stuff we got
to watch i mean that's cute you know
what
my kid they they i mean uh my son boston
is one and a half he's into like uh
the [ __ ] trucks like anything with
trucks yeah but
uh really his number one thing is uh
like dozier cat music videos he'd love
yeah
yeah interesting i always knuckle him up
i'm like hell yeah hell yeah
yeah it might be bad parenting but
whatever yeah but my kids my kids
i know dude my kid is obsessed with
watching
well she was now she's a little older
but she was obsessed with watching
cartoons on youtube in russian
she would watch them in russian all the
time yeah my son tiger will watch it in
[ __ ] chinese yeah she just i think
because they think like the language is
like so different than ours and they
think it's like funny they think it's
like a made-up language
yeah or something which it is because
the only real language is america
have you have you gone on yes hashtag
america america
have you started doing like uh parent
dates like daddy dates
because your daughter played with
somebody's kid and then yeah the parents
come over
yeah it's like a blind date yeah yeah
it's a blind date you have to do that
dad
oh yeah dude i know random strangers in
your house yeah and you just
listen to this [ __ ] dad's startup and
then you just you know he's like listen
then he's like are you going to put this
in your skit
no stupid shut your [ __ ] mouth yeah
i'm not going to put it in your might
that's funny use that on stage i'm like
are you gonna
stand on stage
shut up dude yeah pitch me your app i
want to [ __ ] drown you in my toilet
bowl with your dumb
kid who looks like he's right on the
brink of autism
uh this guy's got a kicker oh my god
this guy's a felony
i was gonna say dude this guy does not
have a home
what's going on [ __ ] oh my god
i love this guy
what's going on [ __ ] got a king
or stinging for you
acting confident when deep down you're
really just a scared beta that needs a
good friend
all right hit me back okay so he was
looking in the mirror hey so
maybe another heineken yeah oh wow
daddy's
whoo danny has more shows today daddy's
wow honey bunny have you had breakfast
bud
no oh my god i don't need breakfast are
we skipping the gym today
well i have to we're starting so early
oh my god what is chappelle going to
think
uh he's all right he has a head cold oh
does he have a head cold
is it a head covid no you sure no
the delta chin if you end up not being
able i'm good brother thank you i got to
be ready for mary lopez
thank you i'll be good i'm used to this
i've been heineken forever
absolutely dude ice get bombed on firing
the kid off whiskey
know i got to stop we've been drinking
too much me and pimping going out
drinking almost every night really at
the garland hotel just wait will you
drink some whiskey with me on saturday
shows
yes oh yeah i'll bring the thick tiger
whisk
hey what's up king of the sting nate out
here from washington state
i got a debate club for you guys so
if you guys rather get tased would you
rather get pepper spray
i've had to do both i need to get
certified with both for my department
dude he's a cop for sure
taser's not bad it's five seconds of
writing the lining
yeah once it's done and done and pepper
spray
that burns like no other it's the worst
for me
yeah definitely he's definitely a cop oh
yeah he definitely let some of those
people into the
the capitol right 100 he definitely
raided the capital but went to the
kitchen first listen i got to be honest
with you
you know the the the the capital
storming thing it was one of those
things where like i had a good time
you know like it was i was the media
makes it look like one thing
but we were just there for our country
doing another thing
you know and it's like i know people get
on everybody like oh you stormed the
capital it's like
i didn't storm the capital was i there
in washington dc on
that date with other friends of mine
who you know think that we have a
problem in this country yes i was yeah
but i didn't go
inside the capitol i did go inside the
capitol
you know they let you in they let me
basically went on a tour of the capitol
i went on a tour of the
i was going you just went to the lunch
room first i was jogging that morning
and then all of a sudden i said who are
these people maybe there's a flea market
and then i went and yes did i have an uh
weapon and q
on flag and all that things but you it
the the country incidents
the country's been in disarray since
biden's been president it's very violent
time so i have to
stay strapped and stay strapped yeah and
i did have a decent time
at the uh at the capitol if that is your
thing it did look fun
it was fun right yeah the lady got shot
in the window but before that it was
can you imagine i got two words being
that [ __ ] lady
out of all the people you were the one
dumbass you got
shot in the [ __ ] neck i know dude and
how about to get she get shot like
oh [ __ ] and then just keep going keep
going well false flag that's all i'll
say
i think i [ __ ] up chris's joke by
making it too dark
you can never make it too dark for me
that's good to know what are the two
words
that you have for me you said you got
two words for me that was false flag
i was saying false flag pepper spray or
uh tasered you ever been pepper sprayed
i've never been pepper sprayed it's
the worst i've had jasmine is throwing
adobo in my face what are you guys gonna
try i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
taser pepper spray no i got i got hit in
the i got hit in the face with a piece
of chicken from jasmine i had like adobo
and sessom on it and that was in my eyes
like a little sriracha dude that hurt
like a puerto rican spicy
chicken to the face because i i was i
was dming people i wasn't supposed to dm
yeah
i've been there so i got that i got that
in the eyes i got that in the eyes bad
and that
i would think i'm sure pepper spray is
even worse but a taser kind of
actually in a way looks like a fun
little way to come i don't know you ever
seen when they taste the cops and they
like [ __ ] their pants
but my point is is like i'd rather have
that i'd rather go through that like a
quick violent shake we [ __ ] your pants
and maybe because spray is an all-day
thing
that's on the next day dude my dad we're
at my grandpa's house
rest in peace we're in my grandpa's
house my dad goes oh look pepper spray
goes i wonder if things still worked
me and my brother i'm like eight we're
standing behind my dad goes all right
guys stand back
but there's a wind and he goes let's see
if it works and he sprays it of course
it [ __ ] works dad
and it [ __ ] sprays out like this
thick
fog of pepper spray sprays out and the
wind goes cool story
boom right in the face to me
i was eight what did it feel like oh
dude
dude really awful my dad for whatever
reason was pouring milk over my eyes
milk yeah yeah that that's like some
somehow the the uh
it's been sure for that battles the
acidity
that's why you take it with hot wings at
you it hurts so bad
got it hot wings i'm gonna go taser all
day
yeah i would go taser all day i would go
taser
taser all day yeah i don't i don't wanna
so you know my father-in-law's a cop
for 30 years he was saying there's
certain people like what a pig
yeah especially especially bigger dudes
that the taser
doesn't work what do you mean some
people it's it's for whatever reason the
taser
like they're too jacked they might be
too jacked or
for whatever reason their body it
doesn't work for them like it does
so it does genuinely nothing does not
work on him so he's like
a big dude we run him they hit him with
a taser and he's just like laughing
pulling it off
dude they're a cop you're [ __ ] your
pants i remember it looks like the
[ __ ] mountain from game of thrones
yeah and the taser doesn't work
dude i read this book called the nazi
symbiosis
it was about like why how the dude it's
a little light reading
um it was easy bubba it was but it was
about how the nazis became the nazis and
what their mindset was
with like the holocaust and all that and
one of the parts of the thing in the
holocaust
what they would do is they figured out
the nazi scientists figured out
obviously through torture and horrible
things
that the thing that gets like excreted
secreted from like your brain
is substance p or something like that
when you call when it
causes pain so they were trying to make
like
eliminate substance p and like do tests
on their nazi soldiers to like remove
substance p
and see if they would feel no pain to
make like the and it was like and i
think they got relatively close
and then the war ended which is wild
dude jesus christ yeah i was like i was
so that's a thing but there are some
people in this world
that have very very low levels of
substance p which causes pain
and they like feel like almost no pain
and and
i oprah used to have like these kids on
and they touch the stove
and yeah they're burning that's the
problem substance p is is a big thing
and actually
actually in the not the nazi symbiosis
book but when i did like further
research about substance p
i forgot the article but a lot of uh
fighters have low levels i bet you have
lower levels of substance p than
the rest of us well what's weird is like
my girl was opening up whatever a
[ __ ] can of tamales or something cut
her finger on it
because they're a typical i hate to say
uh [ __ ] hot peppers and the can like
cut her finger like sliced it
but i think because i'm so conditioned
to like i see
horrible [ __ ] or fighting or whatever
videos i watch in world star hip hop
i'm so like just conditioned to it
she's freaking out i don't give a mirror
too i'm like no oh no [ __ ] band-aid
on it man
yeah and get over it you just knew yeah
but you know
yeah it's just like shut up come on dude
one time
this was like a a year ago right before
jasmine got
uh pregnant with our second daughter she
literally dude i mean i'm talking about
it was done like a
full pot with water of tortellini like
full pot
done like she was going to pour it into
the thing fully as hot as it can be you
drain it
bro the le the handle broke off the pot
it spilled
all over her feet barefoot feet dude
she like it was literally one like
everywhere
she like fell to just freddy krueger bro
and was screaming
screaming dude screaming i know dude
screaming in pain
and she literally like still to this day
is so mad at me because when that
happened i like rushed
to her aid but i had to finish a fire
tweet that i had first
i swear to god in the middle of tweeting
something
that like i thought was like really
funny and i like
literally like the cup and then like got
her eventually but still to this day
she's like what the [ __ ] like i can't
believe you didn't immediately run to me
i'm like babe like you got to tweet at
certain times it's algorithm stuff
yeah and but dude but but it's crazy
because she literally just drank a
bottle of wine
took for advil and just [ __ ] sat
there and it was
dude her feet were blistering up but
just took it i would have went to the
emergency room i would have been like
dead on the floor but i think from the
pain of childbirth that's what i was
gonna say there's a higher pain
tolerance like if you were to
hear a girl like oh yeah tattoos don't
really hurt i like them like you're
insane dude when i just my you know my
kid was just born three weeks ago and i
was you know there because she got the
episode
section she did the right no regular
regular daddy-o but she got the epidural
which you know takes away some of the
pain but you still feel excruciating
pain but her leg went dead
from the epidural which happened
sometimes so i had to hold her leg and
be there and the doctor was like yo you
have to like
be in position like helping like that to
do a quick course like what you need to
do
so i was like in the position bro
literally bro
the doctor's hands were in jasmine like
that yeah like
that dude the openings i was like yo
that's [ __ ] stretchy
and i was like are you feeling this she
was like what do you [ __ ] think
yeah i was like i feel great
[Laughter]
dude i mean i was like watching a child
birth
it's like it's a different so intense it
is so intense
it's very barbaric it's barbaric and
then it's weird
like having a little little baby it's so
strange because it's like
every kid's ugly when they come out oh
yeah no dude dude my daughter literally
she was born she looked like an old
chinese man now she looks like a young
ukrainian woman it's very it's just they
go through these phases and she looks
like different people every day every
day i'm like who is this kid
like i i would be confident if you put
my baby
in the like nursery at like day five i
would not know which one my kid is
no i would have no idea what my kid
looks like because they changed but it's
weird because like
you know she's laying like when i look
at her talk to her like face time with
her now if i've been away for a couple
of weeks
it's like she like her br well yeah dude
well i had to go away last week and i'll
be away for another week because it's
[ __ ] true tv show
um but but every time i know dude just
go to christycomedy.com go support my
life stand up dates most of them are
sold out what can you do
um but go check to see if i'm coming to
your city nashville
uh october foxwoods theater fox
connecticut october 23rd
which is a tough one philadelphia we got
all that wakeen illinois and all these
other ones go check it out miami florida
just put that on sale danny
prov another big one baby dania improv
never heard of it five hundo seats
though four shows
what what can you do
what's it called dania improv dania
point
because danny improv offered poppy a
little bit more money in seats
how far is that and also miami improv
didn't offer me anything
uh that's the big how far is it from
where baby tampa
tamp by the way i'm doing the tampa
theater january 2022. um um um
tampa from miami is pretty far it's far
it's on the other side dania improv is
in between
miami and uh fort lauderdale it's in
between i was just thinking you should
have your cats
athlete
last time i was at miami improv i was
working the logan paul floyd mayweather
fight
i got done with my work with show time i
was like i need to get on stage
so i called miami improv super close
with them i go hey just looking for like
10 minutes i gotta get on stage while
i'm here
like cool but it's mrs pat's weekend let
me i love mrs pat
i don't know mrs pack she's cool but
they asked her and she's like oh yeah i
know brendan from rogan and yeah
yeah tell him he can do 10 minutes yeah
i didn't realize she's basically the
joey diaz of females
oh yeah all black crowd oh yeah so i go
i go out there it goes well
i get then i get i'm walking back she's
so nice love her so talented so nice
she's great before the show i walk back
she gets on stage after me
roasts the [ __ ] out of me for being
white i love him
she goes y'all laughing at that [ __ ]
white boy at my show i'm like what the
[ __ ] dude i love too like black people
now like their definition of white is
just getting bigger and bigger like he
is not white and he goes on
as the big brown tour and it's just like
he's like that white [ __ ]
i'm like no no dude you don't know what
white is okay
that is not why dude nick's white he has
velcro sneakers so white
uh this guy made it cool with it this
guy's on cocaine
theo brandon nick chin
the main man meatball i got a quick game
uggs for men
well those are dope as [ __ ] those are
fires
those are fires yeah
nothing like a little rat fur and some
honey leather
touching your bare ankles on a crisp 100
degree
new jersey morning let me know what
y'all think
gang gang ugg ugg this guy's pushing
for the cartel yeah and he's from new
jersey as soon as he said as soon as you
said meatball i said this guy's from the
east coast
this guy's from dude here's the thing
about uggs obviously they're super gay
right but tomorrow tom brady wears hugs
so
[ __ ] cool man i had a pair around the
house i had the loafers around the house
even my son made fun of me but i still
rock them
when i say things are super gay like i
don't mean that in a negative way it's
like it's just the fact that super
gay is being cool but i mean it's gay
tom brady's gay i don't care he wins all
the super bowl but he's i mean he's a
gay kid
yeah sure you know i mean he's just a
girl like tom brady of course dude i
love gay people but it's like yeah dude
it's fully get dude you're like you're
gay i'm legitimately gay yeah
you know we're both gay i mean look
you're wearing white pants well they're
they're they're denim but yeah they're
white you think they're white they're
like a
cream no this is white we got one more
who's this dude this guy first of all
this kid
is a proud boy i was gonna say look at
those traps bud
yeah traps for days daddy look at that
built like a stingray he's one of those
yeah his hair looks good from this angle
but you can tell
it's just hanging on he's about to go
bald first team all german here
theo brendan i gotta do it looks like
chris whoa i wish i could freeze it
looks like me dude i wish
i was just talking to my girl on the
phone and she said she
wipes front to back
but i got an argument with her and i say
i work
back to front girls have to wait they
have to do that which which way is the
real way
no they have to gang but you have two
sons yeah but i'm a [ __ ]
smart human being so i know women have
to wipe the opposite way because of
the bacteria right the bacteria yeah but
i i didn't know that in the beginning oh
really yeah because i wasn't sure
i literally i just wanted to talk about
it on stage and i literally when
the first one of the first days i was
alone with my daughter when me and her
mom
split i she asked me to like wipe her in
the bathroom but her mom would always do
it and i
didn't know which way to go and i had to
tuck it back and figure it out yeah
and i did but it's of course it's front
to back because you don't want to get
the poopy back
poopy in the in the poo poo yeah yeah
but it happens anyway i mean i've
cleaned more [ __ ] out of a vagina than
like
so you guys that's what i do all day you
guys are both back to front
for wiping my ass yeah oh no i'm i'm uh
i'm i'm uh no you go from the behind you
lean forward
and you go and i go up yeah yeah i i
literally but i don't even know if i do
that i just go straight up
you know what i mean yeah i go straight
i don't [ __ ] around
no no i literally i i put tissue paper
wrapper around my finger
and i go like that and i clean it out
swirl i clean it out not me i
i get hard in there almost like a like a
spoon i also
stand up fully straight when i need to
wipe my ass
stay seated do you stay up do you stand
up straight i put my leg up on the
toilet seat to like really get in
that's disgusting that's disgusting
meatball
body party so that was good yeah dude
i've
never in my life i've never in my life
and i never will in my life use a bidet
i'm not gonna do it i don't care dude
have you ever used one yet no but i
don't i no i don't want to i don't want
i don't want water nice dude
but cold water in your [ __ ] not cold
especially those new like fancy bidets
it's warm water
dude but my question to you is what but
don't you
do you feel like your asshole's cleaned
out with just water spray it couldn't be
more clean
especially the new ones it like sprays
it and it's warm it like
gets everything at the crib no my
friends do though
nice that's it that's it damn that was
quick
well go to christycomedy.com yep all
although it sounds like
your tickets are sold out no well
they're still no you said they were we
just ended up seats in philly
and at the fox [ __ ] well foxy the sec
first show was sold out second show
let's just say please go to
christinecomedy.com
and buy some tickets october 23rd uh i'm
at hahas in la first sets in la this
weekend friday saturday
friday shows or the early show sold out
second show has
five tickets left that will be me eric
griffin and some other
uh friends and then saturday will be me
and chrissy d
that's a ha ha in l.a tickets at
thickboy.com or fatkz.com
and then end of the month i'm in tacoma
washington tacoma comedy club
and then we got a bunch of other dates
coming up all right love you guys
theo we miss you chrissy d thank you
baby
hello love you guys brennan and theo
fighter and weight i got to go in and go
hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms
a couple of you tribal couldn't beat
them quit playing like nintendo ds you
don't want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
king and the sting king and the stink oh
yeah
king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you